I want to give you some quick tips that
you want to keep in mind whenever you're
doing an abdominal assessment so the
first thing what you want to do is you
want to inspect that abdomen but then
you want to auscultate normally we would
do auscultation last but here we don't
want to go poking and prodding on the
patient through percussion and palpation
because we may throw off our assessment
then whenever you go to auscultate you
want to start in a specific place the
right lower quadrant and the reason for
this is because this is normally where
you should hear bowel sounds because the
ileocecal valve is there which connects
the small and the large intestine then
you are going to go clockwise to all the
other quadrants and listen so you should
hear about five to Thirty bowel sounds
per minute if you hear anything less
than that that's hypoactive if you hear
anything more than that that's
hyperactive and if you don't hear
anything after five full minutes it's
considered absent and then lastly
whenever you go to listen for those
breweries you want to use the bell of
your stethoscope because this is the
best part of your stethoscope that
allows you to hear those low pitch
noises